je m'étonne que en amont de l'examen par
l'assemblée il n'y a pas eu déjà dans la
volonté de présenter un texte à
l'assemblée nationale qui n'ait pas déjà
été pour partie soumis à une partie de
la majorité sénatoriale pour arriver dès
le début à une version qui soit une
version qui permettent de ne faire
qu'une lecture françois hollande a dit
rajouté lors de son entretien télévisé
qu'il ne fallait pas qu'elle n'avait
dure trop longtemps est ce que ça
voudrait dire
selon vous que ce texte pourrait très
bien s'arrêter il ya même pas encore eu
une lecture au sénat que le président
explique déjà qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait
trop de navettes parlementaires
enfin j'ai là pour le coup si vous les
otites de la séparation n'est pas le
voir la moindre des choses
le sénat ont participé d'attendre qu'ils
aient une lecture au sénat et de
regarder ce qui se passe après et ce
serait le comble que l'exécutif essaye
de faire porter la responsabilité d'une
navette parlementaire au sénat alors
même qu'il a bricolé un texte sans
prendre le soin de s'assurer de l'accord
de tout le monde avant de le présenter
devant la représentation nationale
ou alors on supprime les institutions et
on considère que quand c'est l'état
d'urgence
le président décide seul où le premier
ministre peut prendre par ordonnance
toutes les décisions qui veut